i haven't watched baseball i can't get i
haven't gotten into this
i couldn't even the islanders i'm a big
islanders fan they're gonna probably go
to the stadium
nhl has been great i just can't for me
man
i don't know why it's just not having
the fans there everything seems like
preseason everything seems like
exhibition and i realized
that i played sports my whole life and i
it's one of those things i'm like do i
not love sports because if i can't watch
it without the fans what
why was i even watching it to begin with
i think i used to just do it
because it's what my dad would make me
do and now he moved to florida and has
he's on [ __ ] dialysis so who knows
he's unconscious half the time yeah but
he's got a little watch it he's got a
little bit of your money so he's got
some money to play around with my dad's
got some juice on the games yeah it's
what it is
did that guy uh did he force you to play
sports
you think he did that that's that was
the thing like my mother would always
say when i was a kid she was like
you know tony he doesn't want to play
and then he'd be like you know my dad
was just like no he does want to play
that back i really don't want to play
he's like you're going to [ __ ] play
and then i would just play you know
basketball and baseball and i remember
one i mean like there was no i remember
one time i got hit by a pitch
we were playing baseball i got hit by a
pitch i was like 11 years old i was
crying at home plate i just wanted
someone to comfort me
and my dad just [ __ ] you know
coaching the game walks out
and he's like rubbing my back you know
he's like you got to stop crying you're
[ __ ] embarrassing me i'm like my back
hurts
i don't want to play the game he's like
are you really going to be this the name
on the back of your jersey you're
embarrassing me
he was like i cannot wait i cannot
[ __ ] wait to get home
because i'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out of
you and then i was just you know it
never happened but i was just
yeah i think for so much of my life i
just played sports
because my dad you know would just make
me do it
like division two scoring record
career the all-time leading scorer in my
college and i never wanted to play the
game but i would just still shoot a
thousand jump shots every day
just play you know baseball basketball
it was just because i wanted my dad to
be proud of me
and uh you know and i guess at the end
he kind of wants
to did you look back after your playing
career and be like what the hell was
that or was
while you were doing it um like the last
six months did you realize like i got to
stop doing this because this wasn't my
dream
i think that it's just we were talking
about before
about like addictions and stuff like
that i think that it's just
all i've done my whole life is just
change addictions that i've had like
first it was basketball and sports
because my dad was like this is what you
want to do and i was like i want my dad
to love me i wanted my dad to be proud
of me i'm addicted to that because he
left
and my family was divorced and i'm like
dad this will make dad proud a thousand
jump shots and then boom
basketball accolades accolades accolades
and then it stops and i'm like oh i
don't want to play anymore so then
it turned to uh getting my mother's love
because my mother would say i remember
my mother said to me once when i was 21
she was like you know i feel like you do
everything for your father and you won't
do anything for me she's like i feel
like you're such a smart
kid and you've never applied yourself
academically and that's all i ever
wanted and all you ever did was prove
stuff to your dad so then i [ __ ] got
into graduate school and got a doctorate
degree
and got a doctorate in physical therapy
because i swear to god i did it for my
mother i just was like putting my head
down and doing it doing it do it and
then i'm doing physical therapy for a
year and i said [ __ ] this
i don't want to do this i want to do
something for me and then i went to the
gotham comedy club open mic
and then i've just been doing this ever
since so i think i'm just changing
addictions and then eventually this will
probably peter out
and i don't know what i'll get out of
here
is now put pressure on you to become the
greatest co-host
in the short time of podcasting history
and then you'll you'll
you'll achieve that too we really hope
you enjoyed that episode whatever it was
about this is just a stock thing that
we're taping on to every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it
and go to patreon.comridgeboys where
things get really wild